hi I'm Rob Lowe we're here at the promo
shoot right now where Rob's getting all
styled up to help promote his own tongue
ration you know people talk about honors
in this town Golden Globes the the Emmys
the Oscars the Comedy Central Roast
trumps Oliver David have you seen your
little girl outfit yeah where are you
didn't speak is sexy I've been asking
David Spade to do the roasts for so long
we go way way back we've been in the
trenches together he's got some some
stories I hope that he does not share I
have to figure out a way to really
on it gracefully when I do these types
of things it's like going to battle I
will hang up pictures of Rob Lowe from
every movie and TV show he's ever been
in the PR team going scramble scramble
make him look tougher throw a motorcycle
the problem with jokes with him are like
they're all really compliments yeah
I never thought it would happen to me
when I was a kid growing up in Ohio my
goals were to become an actor star in
movies to have a long career and to be
made fun of by people who are a lot
uglier than I am